yeah i had i had the luxury of sons of
anarchy for seven years when my daughter
was first born so yeah i go to work in
the morning i could come home at night
which was fantastic are you still close
with those guys
yeah that's a friendship they'll stay
you know that's not going anywhere i saw
charlie not long ago i see boone a lot i
see kim i see theo yeah we always bump
into pearlman perlman or the pair i love
the peril was he fun to work with he's
the best he's such a sweetheart and he's
so he's such a beautiful human being and
i love his politics and he's so eloquent
i mean
he's just he's just he's just a
beautiful man you ever work with any
actors or you're just like i can't wait
till this [ __ ] ends i can't stand
this [ __ ] woman or man or whoever
oh god without saying we need to stop
naming names though
hey guys i'm tom welling i used to play
clark kent on smallville i'm michael
rosenbaum i used to play lex luthor on
smallville join us every week as we go
back
way back i'm excited i know are you
can't wait join tom welling and michael
rosenbaum every week as they rewind
every episode of smallville and discuss
their experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast i think we just
stopped i think we just stopped naming
[ __ ] should we shall we call
them out i don't think so okay i mean
for you you'll probably here's what i
don't give a [ __ ] you won't give a [ __ ]
you'll say it and then you call me you
know rosie [ __ ] we probably should bleep
it no uh i have
oh [ __ ] there's one guy oh
god how bad was he and what made him bad
to work with but
because he was he was so he's so
he's so full of himself for a start and
the most talentless [ __ ] actor
i've ever seen in my life and yet he's
huge
he's huge
and he makes so much [ __ ] money and
he does all these [ __ ] non-stop
movies and it's just
it's agonizing and i think good luck to
you son i'm happy you have a career but
you are a terrible [ __ ] human being
the one i met anyway what was what was
it that makes up someone else the way he
treated the crew exactly were [ __ ]
peasants peasants or some [ __ ] you know
and it was just just
gold me and i just i had to pull him up
and say you know what you don't speak to
other human beings like that he's just
[ __ ] doing and what do you say to you
oh i was just joking tommy i was just
joking you know who you are [ __ ]
yeah well just joking so that was it you
had to work with him for a while i had
the whole movie
this was like day two or something
in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere but
anyway that was all right we we figured
yeah i've had to work with people
there's been a few that i just like i
just
i just feel like oh i can't
they care just so much about themselves
why i don't know it's just like it's
about only about them
it's they're manipulative i've had that
and you just have to you have to just
somehow you have to come together as a
little community or a family whatever
you want to call it because it because
it's there on the screen when it's all
said and done there it is on the screen
you see the connection to chemistry
whatever you want to call it and
yeah you have to every single person has
to be equal you want to say the name so
badly i want to i won't really want to i
won't let you i know thank you rosie
yeah